due scritte appena apri gioco gioca
l'opzione fa sempre piacere che prendono
traduttori capaci per tradurre i
videogiochi bella tutti ragazzi e
benvenuti a questo nuovo video sono fa
vj ed oggi siamo sul futuro che in
italia non è piede e roccia piede roccia
tanto non credo si possano lamentare
della traduzione lievi comincia ragazzi
episodio 1 e la madonna amata roma c'è
oddio cos'è sta roba aiuto cosa da fare
io e il rock è perché ci sono dei perché
ci sono dei dei profumi per automobile
sì ma stai zitto perché ci sono dei
profumi per automobile che se devo fare
fine round nel procedere ragazzi non ho
capito quel problema nasce su tizio che
va avanti da solo quindi ad solo usare
il mouse ami del teletrasporto
si sa che figata bene ma questi sono gli
hater un po di merda sono quelli inglesi
che non capisco come l'italiano non si
dice speso cice venduto suite dei fiumi
di devo lanciandola lanciare o perfetto
questa è la palla balla la teletrasporto
fini frate se parli di miss concentri te
lo giuro cioè con tutto l'amore del
mondo stai zitto che io ho una certa
grazie grazie grazie
no come ho fatto a mancare l'ultima ciao
zio ovvero oggi è morto cosa che anche
suo fatto ragazzi schiudendo non vuole
ve lo giuro che non ho tempo
ok perfetto
mi spiegate qual è il profumo per cosa
serve il profumo per auto vi prego
c'erano sto non lo capisco comunque
ragazzi non dovreste stupirvi dei giochi
che faccio sempre al piano diventa
sempre più bravo non dovreste stupirvi
dei giochi che faccio perché pian piano
vedete che migliora la qualità dei
videogiochi che porto sul canale
il creatore di sto gioco cosa minchia si
è fumato prima di farlo non mi perdo vi
ho bisogno di una risposta seria grazie
ok ok a me fermi ti prego andiamo su
l'opzione possiamo aumentare la grafica
del gioco che prima era questa che era
il minimo
e adesso posso mettere alla grafica al
massimo
god of war può accompagnare sono
migliorata la grafica questa mucca
veramente vera adesso meno male che ho
fatto questa cosa che mica potevo
continuare a giocare con quella grafica
pessima adesso si sta zitto frate che i
grappoli moneda prima che tu nascessi
ma chi è che gli ammessi sti cosi
inutili mi spiegate che li ha messi in
giro gli après magik porca eva schifosa
maledizione 6 zitto sentite prenderò
affanculo con la moneta d'oro sbattuto
ho giocato a sta roba perché volevo
giocare qualcosa di tranquillo
ok por qué loach è successo
pensavo di aver deviato il barile che mi
stava arrivando addosso con la palla
c'era la roba della vita questa porca
vacca prima volta che faccio in europa
[ __ ] schiavi frate devi stare zitto vi
state concentrando ora ma allora fammi
capire ai un calo di zuccheri ogni tanto
qual è il tuo problema
porca eva perfetto perfetto l'effetto
olè magari stavolta forse sega del bari
neve ok rispetto magari non dovevo e
carlo barile mita stato sono i
proiettili più veri che io abbia sparato
in un videogioco c'è mica quanto vero
certo perché la lama non mi sembrava
pericolosa l'inizio perché mi sembrava
lasagna però non c'è un fatto caso
grande porca orali
guardali tanti ragazzi proiettili si
auto direzionano come possibile sta roba
molte volte ragazzi prima di andare a
dormire mi chiedo come faccia giocare
questi giochi di merda cioè ogni tanto
mi faccio questa domanda non sono
anch'io era sincera o perfetto per va
bene le casse di amazon in faccia fanno
sempre piacere le lame no però va bene
importante che li che emerga il tuo zio
questo commentatore mi mette più foga di
fabio caressa cos'è sta roba
perfetto solo quello doveva evitare non
ce l'ho fatta ma in realtà era 20
ragazzi sono fighissimi problema e tutto
il resto del gioco che non lo è però era
lì chi è veramente figo
ok perfetto recapiti passerebbe fiero di
me nel vedermi giocare a certa merda del
suo tensione ok a occhio che questo
schiattato prima bravo qualcuno la mucca
non siamo vegani
ma lei ragazzi ho preso il giro
l'importante è capire come si gioca
mi avete dato della birra con la mucca
linee che cazzo cosa cosa è successo
questa mi placcano addirittura sei
cosa ha pià carmi l'ho preso e svenuto
perfetto grande m by gucci opachi nel
pezzo metto sto video davanti a un palco
raga siamo a posto
lo ha spiegato il perché il gioco è una
merda la grafica è una merda vai tutto
cagare ma la musica è bellissima com'è
possibile
ma voglio la soundtrack visto giornate
mila soundtrack per l'amor di dio cioè
roba da fare invidia al signore degli
anelli come scolano sonora che cazzo
oddio c'era un dock c'era un castello di
carte ci manca solo quello guarda salve
mi sa che se non mi sposto sono nella
merda qui mi è arrivato alle volte
meglio perché mi placca un avversario
però mi è arrivato un container di 200
kg in testa e sono ancora vivo come
possibile mica posso sentire le paste
che salgono posso sentire franchino alla
consolle
a tutti sulle mani
ma quanto è bello costruito su questo
gioco c'è una cosa che non vi ho detto
cioè io io io ho pagato 10 euro
questa merda perché l'ho fatto però la
musica li merita tutti solo la musica
bisogno di più dell'oro quella utenza
grassetto rispetto a tutta la scritta in
grassetto mi esprime senso di
inadeguatezza
non so se per voi la stessa cosa
programmata visto il gioco la
programmato questa musica di sottofondo
alla normale che gioco si è così un po
di polvere magica se la sarei narrata di
sicuro perché non può aver fatto se cose
da sobrio e impossibile ora programmato
lapo elkann sto gioco non lo so io non
capisco erba viola transenne monete
gommoni matite giganti iran e che
saltano bus pale eoliche pipistrelli
cielo non va veramente ma roba veramente
forte si è calato il tizio prima di
programmare una fortissima
ce la possiamo fare finestra livello che
è mica ministro gioco mi mette veramente
ansia sono affatto rari incredibile
advise io e zio credo in te jolo
e vabbè ma le super hot è diventato
superò la custodia 10 euro speso a
[ __ ] lawrence di calabria allora
ragazzi fermi tutti che 10 euro gli
hobbit ari 10 euro che ben buttati nella
mia vita
vai così vai vai che ci arrivò mai che
ci arrivo colpiscilo prima che ti
blocchi
fare due regi game di fila l'ho fatto
ieri adesso lo faccio anche oggi non è
salutare cioè io lo dico per la meglio
il dottore ma consiglia mi ha detto
proprio fa vincere non fare due regi
game di fila perché non è proprio il
massimo a livello di salute ma c'ha
ragione non era sorta schifosa allora
[ __ ] è detto che porta la data
fortissima è una madonna
questo è svenuto
ok ok occhio perfetto l'ultima ho letto
l'ultimo livello raga l'ultimo senza mai
morire lo voglio fare senza morire
proprio così subito 6 zini casto qua
parte all'inizio del video vi dà un
fastidio che fino adesso ci siamo devo
schivare i più veloci
ora che è impossibile scrivere gli
pneumatici anche perché c'erano coraggio
espositivo pensato tutti sfide
trasportasse ole ole ma non era così
difficile era l'ultimo livello che
sicuramente fermi fermi fermi episodio 2
va bene così ma io basta famiglia
spegnere anzi non teniamo la musica
perché bella io direi che dopo dopo
questo video prendo il posto di tudor
come dj perché tunz tunz equa
gabry ponte può accompagnare non lo so
come sia disposti sotto effetto di lsd
dopo giornata sta roba cioè impossibile
ragazzi miei spero che vi sia piaciuto
spero che siate sobri spero che capiate
che questo gioco in realtà il futuro dei
videogiochi perché 10 euro spesi nel
2017 ti portano a questo e pensare che
la pole in sconto che giornata di merda
ma se il gene ricerca un commento è un
mi piace anche vari social che come
dicono a tornare descrizione cioè se
rapidi 16 vediamolo conseguito bello
ragazzi che belle non li guarderò il
video mille volte giuro
[Musica]